donc
revenons à ce que je disais avant
ma théorie oh mon dieu um steve rogers n'avait pas de
petite amie avant d'entrer dans
le service
dit qui
la chaîne d'histoire alors il devient
capitaine américain et à partir de ce moment
un symbole de l'amérique il est précipité au
en première ligne, il devient un héros de guerre, puis
il est gelé dans la glace, donc d'après
tout ce que vous m'avez dit, après qu'il
se soit dégelé, il passe d'une
catastrophe mondiale
menaçante à une catastrophe mondiale menaçante, c'est quand il n'est
pas un fugitif de la loi, alors ça
on dirait qu'il était assez occupé, tout
ce que vous faites est de répéter tout ce
que je vous ai déjà dit à propos de mon
ami et collègue, évidemment,
Captain America était vierge
dans l'univers cinématographique merveilleux, les
gens sont protégés par deux groupes distincts mais
tout aussi importants le  les héros qui les
sauvent et les avocats qui nettoient
leurs dommages collatéraux mais un seul peut
être les deux c'est son histoire d'un avocat montre
qu'elle tient une comédie juridique comme nous
n'en avons jamais fait  e avant que
tout se lève,
il est de retour maintenant d'accord aura calmez-vous
ce qui est amusant ce sont les types de
personnages merveilleux qui viennent lui demander des
conseils juridiques aucun juge ne prendra cela au
sérieux à moins que nous ne fassions les choses selon le
livre oh
le livre de la cabane non le livre  of
american uh loss
[Music]
c'est une émission de droit comme ali mcbeal ou
pratique
et puis ça enfreint toutes ces règles
le plaisir de l'émission est de combiner ce
monde juridique et toutes les possibilités
autour de l'
étrangeté des super-héros
appelle mon avocat
je veux juste être  un avocat anonyme normal
,
nous repoussons vraiment les limites que d'autres
émissions n'ont pas avant la
clôture de l'affaire, c'est
fait